WASHINGTON TO AVOID A LEGAL
SHOWDOWN WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Shannon: THANKS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP MAY LOOK TO ROLL
BACK ANOTHER LEGACY REGULATIONS
THAT COULD COST YOU MONEY.
HERE'S DOUG.
>> THE EPAN ADMINISTRATOR MAY
SEE NEW HATE COME PROGRESS
APRIL 1st.
>> THE PRESIDENT PUT ME IN
TRUST PEOPLE ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY.
>> IN 2012 THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION PUT THROUGH NEW
STANDARDS.
REDUCING FOSSILE FUEL
CONSUMPTIONS AND GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS.
AT GREAT EXPENSE TO THE
AUTOMOBILE INDUSTRY.
>> IT ADDS TO CAR PRICES AND
RESTRICTS CAR CHOICES.
THE WORST THING IT MAKES CARS
LESS SAFE.
YOU INCREASE THE MILES PER
GALLON BUT DECREASE ITS CRASH
WORTHINESS.
>> ADDING TO THAT IS FUEL
ECONOMY STANDARDS THAT WOULD
FURTHER INCREASE COSTS.
CALIFORNIA HAS ITS OWN TOUGHER
FUEL STANDARDS.
HIS ATTORNEY GENERAL VOWED TODAY
TO MAINTAIN THOSE STANDARDS
REGARDLESS WHAT HAVE THE EPA
DOES.
TWEETING THAT CALIFORNIA WILL
TAKE STEPS NECESSARY TO PROTECT
OUR PLANET AND PEOPLE.
THE ASSOCIATED PRESS CONTACTED
15 CLIMATE SCIENTISTS WHO SAID
THE TALKING POINTS DON'T REFLECT
REALITY.
THE EPA WON'T COMMENT ON HOW
MUCH FUEL ECONOMY STANDARDS WILL
CHANGE.
THE FINAL DETERMINATION WILL BE